but the pleasures continuing the search  good ball movement player movement amino  knocks down to three  and there's Harvey back let it easy and  one great option that have to stretch  the floor but Joe Johnson's going to be  a great addition for these guys as they  finish out to spread their season eight  on the clock here  [Applause]  by Ed Davis hello James Harden okay  terrific defense file on the clock  Oh James step back oh yes  to the hottest players in the league  gets inside scores card not Miller five  on the clock tries to shake mouse gets  inside  first nine points of the game in the  first quarter of the Houston he's got  the first nine here in the third drop to  capela watch  stunt by lured park Mesquite Foust  Martin right on the face in the end one  by James Hart the second  Gary Payton impersonation by trying to  get a stop and he couldn't  we're on the clock  step back  [Applause]